hello and welcome to the Daily climate
show coming up
hundreds of activists in Germany are
ordered to leave an abandoned Village
that's due to be cleared for the
expansion of a massive Coal Mine after
their last ditch Court efforts fail
a five-year-old boy is Swept Away by
flood waters and two people are hit by
Falling trees as the death toll in the
storms sweeping across California hits
14.
[Music]
and after a year of record temperatures
droughts and wildfires Europe officially
records its second hottest year on
record in 2022 with only 2020 being
hotter
foreign
to the Daily climate show where we track
the changes to our world and investigate
some of the potential solutions to The
Climate crisis now our top story this
afternoon a court in Germany has
rejected a last-ditch attempt by climate
activists to stay in an abandoned
Village that's due to be cleared for the
expansion of a massive opencast coal
mine now the utility company rwe wants
to extract the coal beneath looks near
the Western city of Cologne saying it
will help energy Security in the country
but activists are refusing and are
attempting to block heavy machinery from
getting in or we can speak now to
Raphael Taylor one of the active
activists on the ground in lutzel Wrath
uh Raphael thanks for joining us on the
daily climate show just give us a sense
of what today's been like have tensions
been high
uh what you see behind me is a standoff
between activists and the police the
police has tried to push into the
Village today they did succeed to gain a
couple of meters but uh for now they
seem to call today because uh the
activists held strong
so Raphael just give us a bit of context
now explain to our viewers exactly why
the village of looks wrath is so
important not only to this Energy
company but to the people trying to stop
it opening
there are 280 million tons of coal
underneath the ground here
um if those will be dug out and burned
this will kick us across the 1.5 degree
limit
um Germany will fail its Paris uh the
agreement that's why we're here and you
were talking about energy security there
are several studies that are saying the
cold here won't be touched within the
next three years so this has nothing to
do with the Russia Ukraine war this is
all to do with profit and the interests
of that utility utility company
and Raphael very briefly what will
happen next now because presumably the
protesters they will be moved on but
where does this leave Germany trying to
reach their climate Ambitions
um ensembles to be honest uh at least
those Ambitions in shambles
um as I said we won't be able to hold
the Paris agreement if Jeremy digs out
this call and that's why the activists
for the past five years have duck in
into this Village there are three houses
there are tunnels and obviously we'll
try as long as possible to defend this
Village and the coal underneath the
ground and Raphael have you spoken to
protesters today are they willing to dig
in and keep coming back
that's what we're here for
um we are already duck in their trenches
they're three houses they're like still
the houses inside the Village
um there's food stocked up and yes uh
we're expecting this we're expecting
that we can resist for a couple of weeks
and we hope that the green party will
make the right decision and will take
responsibility for the climate and call
off this police action call off this
action that profits no one but that big
company and they are shareholders okay
Raphael Taylor and thank you for talking
to us from the village of luxurath in
Germany there
take a look at some of the other stories
making news today for you and new
developments in England will have to
include sustainable Drainage Systems
from 2024. now the environment
department is bringing in regulations to
reduce the risk of flooding and sewers
being overwhelmed by heavy rain now
measures such as so-called rain Gardens
ponds and green roofs could be built to
help soak water away into the ground
environment Minister Rebecca Powell says
the scheme is vitally important for
protecting the country against the
effects of climate change
climate change is happening and we know
that we will have to expect more
extremes of weather whether at both
phones a more extreme Rave but also more
drought so we that's why we are planning
that's why resilience and water
resources are so important so we've got
a huge piece of work for a holistic
approach on all of this as we go forward
and it and it's it's critical obviously
as a government that we have water to
use uh and that we are but then we are
also safe from flooding and that's why
we got this 5.2 billion pound flood
budget
the Met Office has issued three yellow
warnings for persistent heavy rain
throughout the day covering much of
Wales and Northwest England now of
course some disruption is to be expected
in those areas including flooding of
homes and businesses spray on the roads
increased Journey times on public
transport and possible power cuts
well there are currently 28 flood
warnings in place across England meaning
flooding is expected and 94 flood alerts
where flooding is possible
and a Lobby group launches today in an
attempt to push kissed armor into making
nature and climate a key part of his
election Manifesto now the labor climate
and environment forum is holding an
event in Westminster with speakers
including Ed miliband and Rachel Reeves
now the group says tackling the climate
and environment emergency is popular
with voters and should be a core labor
value
and after another record-breaking summer
of soaring temperatures heat waves and
droughts it's perhaps unsurprising that
2022 has officially been declared the
second hottest year on record in Europe
only 2020 was hotter or globally it was
also the fifth hottest year on record
that's according to the eu's climate
change service now the group says the
last eight years have been the eight
hottest years on record as the planet
continues to warm
now California is facing a Relentless
string of storms at the battering
coastlines washing away roads and
turning Rivers into gushing flood zones
now thousands have been evacuated from
towns with histories of deadly mudslides
14 are so far known to been killed with
a five-year-old boy being Swept Away by
rushing flood waters our correspondent
sabachoudry has the latest
an unusual site for California
[Applause]
famous for its beaches the golden state
has its known is now underwater
state of emergency with no bounds
more than a dozen people have died
and the desperate search for a
five-year-old who was on his way to
school has been called off because of
the danger to divers or they're found so
far is one shoe
here in Montecito there's a tragic sense
of nostalgia an evacuation order is now
in place five years to the day a
Mudslide killed 23 people
some of the locals include celebrities
like Oprah the sussexes and Ellen
DeGeneres
ever
[Music]
probably about nine feet up we need to
be nicer to Mother Nature because Mother
Nature is not happy with us
severe storms have battered the town and
tens of thousands of people have been
without power
ironically drought warnings are the norm
around here so for locals the impact of
the flooding has hit hard a huge Branch
harpooned my roof and I live in a small
Studio
and we could have been killed by it with
over a ton
like I chose to go for a walk today
and count my blessings and see if there
is anybody else I can help neighborhood
solidarity and a dose of normality
helping weather the storm
for now subachowdry Sky News
the climate Show with Tom Heap returns
this weekend at 3 30 and 7 30 that
Saturday and Sunday and if there's
something you want to know about climate
change or the environment you can scan
the QR code now send us your questions
and we'll do our best to answer them
well that's all from us today we're back
tomorrow at the same time for now though
back to SJ